[Music]
hey man
well i tell you maurice i got really
strong feelings
about the topic
of
how chess
the generation of today
versus our generation old school versus
new school year old school versus new
school
these youngins don't know anything about
the old school stuff
but you know this is the this is where i
got the strong strong feelings but mixed
feelings
like
i love
the fact
that i had a germans i learned so much
through analysis and studying
and doing myself chess was a mystery
right it was a mystery it was great
a lot of times we didn't know what was
really going on we didn't we didn't we
had to press ourselves and really dig
deep into the position
and
i missed having an opponent i really did
i was like i was 12 13 when i got
started nobody wanted to beat up on me
but nobody wanted to lose either so i
was like always sitting watching
because from afar because i couldn't get
a game right
now you got an opponent 24 hours a day
anytime you not just an opponent
somebody's strong 3 600 opponent you
know you got to play
time you want
man getting the games the data you know
like the bulletins of the soviet
championship that was like
oh three months later three months later
you thought about some games right that
was played somewhere in moscow or nick
sichu or someplace in the world
and nowadays it's automatic it's it's
it's live when you get it six million
database of games i you did six million
it's like eight nine million now yeah
where are you
it's unbelievable so i'm in
insanely jealous of
the kids of today the generations today
all the tools they have the internet
chess was different maurice chess was
different gary kasparov said it well the
other day blitz chess was five zip
three's it if you were a maniac you know
you're three three you mean no
increments no
time was the time the hands were like
this shaking you're right you're banging
clock yeah
wait a minute fix the pieces right what
are you doing on your time and you
didn't know how much time you had left
today
how much time i got
like
then you made the time control you made
the time control
and the flag never fell like one minute
two three minutes you had been bashing
the clock like nothing and like you had
more time than you thought no nowadays
they know to the to the tenth of a
second right how much time they had left
and the thing is
even just the idea of studying books
right books books what are books tyro
doesn't look at books you look at books
wow they got the databases they got the
engines
that's it you just ask the engine what's
the right move here exactly you don't
need somebody to tell you that the
principle in this position is to control
the center right a break in the middle
the computer says screw your break in
the middle
it's mating six right this wins that's
it you're you're talking nonsense that's
what uh lavonne had said in an interview
he says
i don't want to spend
20 hours studying and open i want to hit
my space bar this is facebook and just
give me the answer
like you know people spend i want to say
lives but that's like a look studying
you know what i'm talking about the
sicilian dragon that was their pet if
you they couldn't play the sicilian
dragon they weren't interested in
playing chess nope and they put
everything their heart and soul into an
opening and today they dropped those
openings like nothing man i got no
commitment to you if you're not
producing the result go and back in the
day you stuck to like three or four very
fearful openings that was a lot that was
a lot like this is what this is what you
play
you know if you play the carrot con
that's right
that's what you do that's it now you see
these guys play six or seven different
things and you know them well that's
like this is like
the sicilian i could play the camera i
could play the french i might throw
modern at you right you never know
toss out an alicon to do something crazy
he said how are these guys playing all
these things and they know the theory
they they only quote the game even if
the game was played a week ago right got
it yeah this was just played
it's incredible just a touch of a button
and the thing though that's got to scare
you
or maybe it frustrates me is when they
start looking at the classics and saying
the classics like why
those guys didn't know what they were
doing you know they were doing like they
made all of these mistakes the engine
shows alekhine's combination was unsound
even though
even though it took years for people to
really analyze the combination was it
sound was it unsound quick story quick
story two guys victor korchnoy tigran
petrosian hated each other i mean
intense this was like the rivalry to end
rivalries and i was victor corchenoy's
coach
and they got together for a candidate
match
a couple draws a couple draws an
adjournment
and they got to this crazy position
coachnoy thought he was winning and i
said victor you got to play g4 no no no
no no ain't playing g4 ain't happening
no no no g4 is terrible we look good
petrosian took a timeout we spent 24
hours seriously michael steen myself
victor we worked hard intensely on this
adjourn position he said
victor you got to play chief
i caught him in a moment of weakness
horrible move rook c8
bang you lose
okay he played the right move h6 h4 he
made the wrong move bang bang bang bang
you lose
finally he plays all the right moves and
it's a draw he says see it's a draw
i go yeah but i think the positions are
dry it was a queen versus two bishops
we go to the playing hall i said victor
you're going to play g4 you know
i go sit down in the audience back back
bling hall dark
and
victor gets to the position instantly
plays g4
hits the clock i want to stand up and
cheer yeah that's my move everybody you
know applaud me that's what i did what i
did
sit down
petrosian
writes down a move ten minutes passes
josie doesn't make a move another 10
minutes pass petrosian doesn't make a
move
35 minutes pass before petrosian makes a
move
and during that 35 minutes
i went through
hell
torments
stone cold absolute fear
what
if i had made a mistake in my analysis
and korchnoy loses
to his most hated
rival this would be terrible right
so i'm in like
after 35 minutes i'm in a trembling
panic
petrosdian plays rook c8 the first move
that victor played against me bang bang
bang bang bang
victor won
today
that movie no mystery instantly yeah
instantly would have been the best move
or the worst move or the right answer
that's why adjournments had to get
booted out right just because of engines
now and you look at openings that used
to be garbage back in the day right
rehab for sure all of a sudden white had
all these advantages back in the day
evaporating in smoke right how
do you think that that has taken
something away from modern chess as it
made it less rich less interesting
or do the players just simply have to be
more creative
yes and yes that's the crazy part it
seems to me that chess evolves with
these new tools whatever they are the
internet increment just evolves
yeah for me i love the mystery of chess
okay that's taken away but look what has
come in its place
these guys play chess more accurately
today than ever that's the truth the
quality of the games are remarkable
incredible they are you know what let's
play
like the old school days yeah baby move
it they didn't i'm good i'm gonna follow
y'all's advice oh yeah you know you're
scared of this in english
you remember them days playing carpark
oh it was so much fun it was sweet it
was sweet he's building a fortress
let me do one of your
favorites okay